Congratulations to all of you for the New Year!
I am very happy to be able to hold the Kagamibiraki ceremony at Aikido Hombu Dojo and see so many of you attending.
There are many people from overseas today, so I would like to read you a speech to facilitate translation.
Last year, as a recovery year after the COVID-19 pandemic, and many events were held safely.
The dispatch of instructors overseas continued to increase and the number of visitors has returned to usual. It was an enriching year.
This year is the year of the snake. Snakes shed their skin, which is said to represent rebirth and regeneration from ancient times.
Additionally, in the Chinese zodiac, this is specifically a year of the wood snake, which is a special year that brings with it useful energy.
In the Aikido world, while continuing to have younger generations further know the excellence of Aikido, cherish the tradition as it has come to us,
and through this, the next generation will better inherit Aikido, which is to say, the Aikido world will bear fruit while shedding its skin.
This year, while continuing to devote ourselves to daily practice and bringing the founder's stated Wagono Seishin, spirit of unity to life in service to the community, let us progress together.
Thank you very much.